So you see up here, it says we're
viewing data for all sessions.
A session indicates a period of
continuous use for your app,
and it's a key concept
in Google Analytics.
So if you use your app for
awhile, say for a few minutes,
and then you put it down, let's say
looking at dinner suggestions makes
you hungry so you go get an ice cream.
And then you eat your ice cream.
It takes you about ten minutes.
And then you go back to your app.
And let's say you've been away
from the app for ten minutes.
So when you go back to the app,
you're actually in the same session.
It's all been considered
one continuous session
because it's been less than
30 minutes of continuous use.
Even though you actually stopped
using it for ten minutes.
But let's suppose now that
you take a longer break.
And you go for a much bigger ice-cream.
This is going to take you longer to eat.
But, again, even though you ate the
whole ice cream, you're still hungry so
you're going to go back to your app.
Now, let's say you were gone from
your app this time for 31 minutes.
In this case, when you go back to
the app, you're going to be in a new
session, because the default period
of time for a session is 30 minutes.